Außenministerin Angelina baerbock und
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck wie
der SPIEGEL berichtete soll zwischen den
beiden nämlich eine grüne Eiszeit
herrschen wir erinnern uns Anfang 2008
als die beiden die Führung der Grünen
übernahmen legten sie ihre Brust
zusammen und lieferten der Presse am
Laufband gemeinsame Fotos wir haben noch
nie der beiden ja das wollförmig über
aus den Fotos wie Kitsch doch damit soll
jetzt Schluss sein bei der gasumlage
sprang einer Lena Werbung habe ich nicht
zur Seite und aus der latenten
Konkurrenz der beiden die durch die
Kanzlerfrage eingeleitet wurde soll
eisige Rivalität entstanden sein dies
Leute im Bundestag schildern wenn man
auf den Unmut vieler Bürger mit der
grünen Politik blickt kommt natürlich
die Frage auf können sich die Grünen
nicht mal mehr selbst leisten das war
jetzt etwas überspitzt aber ich frage
mal Jan Schäfer als Leiter des Politik
und Wirtschaft Resorts bei Bild wie
steht es denn zwischen einer Lena
Werbung und Robert haben Weg ja du hast
es eigentlich ganz gut beschrieben die
haben das in den letzten Wochen ja auch
immer wieder bei uns online in der
Zeitung oder auch bei BTV dokumentiert
das aus den ziemlich besten Freunden
eigentlich mittlerweile ziemlich beste
Feinde geworden sind haben auch mal die
Frage gestellt wie sehr sich Annalena
baerbock eigentlich über den Absturz von
Robert Habeck freut denn wir wissen ja
auch das ging ja auch mal andersrum wenn
wir an den Sommer 2021 denken kurz vor
der Bundestagswahl dann war es Annalena
bärburg die in sehr sehr schwerer See
war als grüne Kanzlerkandidatin und
keinen richtigen Beistand eigentlich von
ihrem ko-partei Chef Robert habe
erfahren hat und das geht jetzt in
umgekehrter Weise so das ist brutal Frau
Hermann noch weiß ja auch ein bisschen
wie die Grüne Partei funktioniert ähm
das ist brutal so ist Politik und Anna
Bock hatte auch ein langes Gedächtnis
und weiß noch ganz genau was Robert
Habeck nicht gesagt hat im letzten
Sommer vor der letzten Sommer und Wasser
gesagt hat und das war nicht besonders
hilfreich für Sie und so ist das Spiel
der Politik jetzt ist sie oben auf und
er unten und am Ende ist ganz klar steht
eine Bundestagswahl 2025 und auf die
schielen beide das heißt Annalena
baerbock kann es nur recht sein dass
Robert Habeck aktuell wahrscheinlich
anders machen ja die Grünen wollen sie
jetzt wahrscheinlich anders machen die
hatten ja damals den beiden die
Entscheidung überlassen und jetzt soll
es aber ja vielleicht auch eine Urwahl
geben wer dann als Kanzlerkandidat
antreten wird war denn dann die Harmonie
und alles nur gespielt oder hat sich das
einfach so entwickelt weil man hat ja
schon wirklich gedacht die haben bald
ein paar Namen so wie Jennifer Lopez und
wenn er fliegt hätte man sich fast auch
noch von den beiden eine hofft habe
kurz davor
2018 2,19 in dieser Phase waren die
Grünen Oppositionspartei und wollten
unbedingt in die Bundesregierung und
hatten immer wieder ein Höhenflug und
dann hätte der ab und das gemeinsame
Ziel war schon die Grünen nach einer
langen Periode in Opposition wieder in
die Regierung zu führen und das schmeißt
natürlich auch zusammen eine Partei die
ja von Flügel kämpfen lebte
beziehungsweise daran auch immer wieder
halb zugrunde ging die brauchte ein paar
an der Spitze was diese Partei
zusammenführt stark macht auch so dass
wir ein chorgeist entwickelt einen neuen
koggeist und das muss man sagen haben
die beiden hinbekommen aber am Ende ist
immer die Frage jeder Politiker
Christoph Meier weiß das auch will am
Ende irgendwie auch Macht haben und es
ist dann schwer zu entscheiden ja er
oder ich ähm und genau das ist bei den
Grünen passiert das hat Robert habe ich
sehr stark getroffen dass er Annalena
beerbock den Vortritt leisten musste hat
ihr das so gut es ging aus seiner sich
dann auch Heim gezeigt in schwierigen
Situation na gut aber es ist auch
payback time jetzt für Anna Lena Bär
Bock und das sehen wir jetzt also es
geht um das Ziel wer wird
Kanzlerkandidat 20 25 und da ist jeder
Meter den Annalena bärburg vor Robert
habe ich aus ihrer sich gut und
umgekehrt ärgert sich natürlich Robert
Habeck über jeden Meter den er hinter
sie zurückhält aber ehrlich mal muss uns
das denn interessieren was in den beiden
vorgeht die Lage ist doch viel zu ernst
dafür dass wir uns damit beschäftigen ob
das ein oder andere selfie mit den
beiden geklappt hat oder nicht wir haben
keine fortschrittskoalition mehr weil
die Lage sich total verändert hat wir
haben einfach ein völlig anderes Jahr
2022 als das Jahr 2021 war dafür können
die Parteien nichts aber die Pläne
können jetzt eigentlich auf den
Müllhaufen der Geschichte die müssen
sich alles neu ausdenken finde ich also
ich würde gerne ein betonier halten für
diesen Industriestandort Deutschland der
kommt mir zu kurz bei dem was die
Bundesregierung macht das sage ich ganz
deutlich ich vertrete auch viele
Mittelständler ich arbeite wie
Mittelständler
heute noch bleiben wir noch einmal bei
den Grünen weil warum
ich das nicht so spannend finde und
warum ich das heute mitgebracht habe mit
einer in der Werbung und Robert habe ist
ja die wurden ja schon auch gewählt weil
sie immer diese Harmonie zu Schau
gestellt haben wir sind anders wir
machen die Frauenquote bei uns hat die
Frau den Vortritt wir sind die
moralischen wir regeln das alles jetzt
zeigt sich anscheinend das ist da ja gar
nicht so das ist ja fast wie schon
wieder eine grüne Lüge so wirkt es auf
mich na ja das ist die Inszenierung das
ist einfach nur die Inszenierung
Parteien inszenieren sich das ist völlig
normal und die Grünen haben immer schon
gerne Ping Pong empfiehlt dann hat man
immer einen der an der Aufmerksamkeit
steht wenn der andere nicht in der
Aufmerksamkeit steht das ist eine
Inszenierung da würde ich mich jetzt
nicht weiter echauffieren das ist eben
der gewählte Weg der Grünen sage ich
jetzt mal der Punkt immer so das war
schon immer so und ähm ja die haben
meistens aber keine Doppelspitzen das
ist aber schon unsere besondere Kniff in
der Inszenierung aber ich würde das
nicht überbewerten die Frage ist viel
mehr was denn eigentlich jetzt das
Rendezvous der Grünen insgesamt mit der
Wirklichkeit bedeutet auch für uns alle
ich glaube wir müssen natürlich
beachten das natürlich beide in der
Öffentlichkeit sehr gehypt waren vor der
Bundestagswahl und am Ende müssen wir
sehen dass beide quasi keine
Übermenschen sind was normale was normal
ist ich habe den Eindruck dass Robert
Habeck gerade lernt dass nur den
Erklärbär geben nicht ausreicht er hat
mit dem Wirtschaftsministerium
Wirtschaft und Energieministerium die
zentrale Position in dieser
Bundesregierung und ähm wir hoffen alle
wir warten dass er da jetzt gute
Vorschläge mit dem Finanzministerium
auch eine sehr zentrale Position aber
für genau die Themen die jetzt relevant
sind gerade für die Industrie gerade für
die Wirtschaft aber auch für die
Menschen draußen über
gaspreisbremsen über strompreisbremsen
reden dann ist das das Thema wo dran
Herr Habeck wachsen oder scheitern kann
mehr von beiden haben momentan
keiner von beiden nervt nervt mich aber
ich glaube schon dass er habe ich
momentan in der zentraleren Rolle ist
und zeigen muss dass er den Job
gewachsen ist
wie ist es denn bei ihnen Herr Nast ja
ich habe ja in dieser Sendung
damals für atemloses Schweigen gesorgt
als ich gesagt habe dass ich die Grünen
wählen werde aber man Monster man muss
dazu sagen dass durch diese
kumpelhaftigkeit oder dieses eigentlich
dieses duzen in diesem es ist Image
Alter ich kann diese Leute also ich habe
echt gerade generell ein Problem mit der
der oberen sei mal politischen Kaste die
irgendwie ernst zu nehmen also bei uns
Bekanntenkreis wir nennen die alle mit
Vorhaben weil da ist überhaupt kein
respektiert wird also das sind irgendwie
was ist ganz ganz seltsam dass ich das
also es ist fehlt wirklich
ja
trotz der Unzufriedenheit ja die
Unzufriedenheit das sind doch alles
imagegeschichten ich meine interessant
ist ja was ich bei Robert Habeck oder
Robert wie ich ja sage in gut finde ist
ja interessant findest das ja ein ganz
anderen rhetorischen Stil hat wir mit
den Leuten redet er sagt letztendlich
wir haben diese Pläne wir wollen das
Umsetzen geht aber nicht kriegen wir
nicht hin Realpolitik aber so ist das
halt ja aber ich glaube die Frage die
letztendlich war wirklich mal erstellt
werden sollte unabhängig von diesem das
ist ja alles was ist das Boulevard diese
diese das ist doch hier nein diese diese
dieses Thema letztendlich was Du hier
aufgebaut also was sie hier aufgehört
haben warum ist ein massives Vertrauen
in die Politiker eigentlich
warum fehlt dann Vertrauen und das ist
manchmal diskutieren was ist das Problem
Deutschland genau